[Music]
all right this guy
from indonesia became
mega rich okay now mega mega rich so he
got about two almost two million dollars
for
this meteorite that crashed into his
home
two millions a lot overnight it's not
like a mega like the way i was painting
how did he crash indonesia that's pretty
rich
yeah yeah for sure i take that [ __ ]
right now me too do you have gold in it
no you i could retire for the rest of my
life with two million dollars yup
oh yeah so the meteorite is valued yes
what makes it that value is it the
materials in it like how does this
world or is it like that like signs what
to pay for it yes science wants to pay
for it
it's that so it's a 4.5 pound
meteor oh it's pretty heavy and it
smashed through
an awning of his home can you imagine
him eating noodles
what the hell is this yeah and then so
he said that even when he went to go
pick it up it was still hot
he tried to pick it up with his bare
hands he knew for a fact it was a
meteorite because there's
no way anyone can throw the rock that
like that hard
and the fact that it was hot too it was
just like oh [ __ ] this came from
space so um they're saying that they're
estimating
to they're estimating that to be about
4.5 billion years old
wow can you imagine that could have
killed him and he would have been the
guy who was killed by a meteor right it
was just so rare it's insane
to have one hit you and kill you landed
in front of him
oh that's the worst luck on earth dude
exactly
i would find that very lucky even the
guys that got the dead person
yeah as the just kidding no um but they
so anyway so they're saying that
this is a extremely very rare
variety of meteorites sounds like it
how many varieties are there yeah
apparently there's plenty and this one's
extremely rare kind because of age
probably
uh they're saying they're classifying it
as a cm1
one and a half or one slash two i don't
know how to say it i'm not nerdy enough
to understand
carbonaceous chondrite okay that's what
it is
and it's valued at around 850 dollars
per gram
which brings it to a total of one
million eight hundred and fifty eight
thousand five hundred and six
fifty six dollars dude they actually
told him that [ __ ]
they didn't just hey it's worth like i
don't know five hundred bucks here you
go
i know right take the phone he so they
even reported like when
there was like the scientists that
wanted to go and like talk to him or
whatever like
it was like that meteorite sent shock
waves through the scientific community
so a whole bunch of people were trying
to get it
they're like where is it at also they
were like outbidding each other yeah
i think because this dude was like he
was negotiating
so yeah he knows yeah yeah like good job
mr indo fried rice from jj's
he was not a dummy here so anyway this
is what it looked like
why did you crash into a ridge i would
not be able to tie that to meteorites if
it crashed into your house would nikki
want to
keep it forever she's like this is a
rock
crystal from space we'd probably have to
keep it i can't even tell
even if they were like this world it's
worth two million dollars
oh she's gonna bring us more she'd sell
it yeah
no maybe you could tip off a little
piece and keep a tiny little piece and
then sell the rest that's not that
okay here we go what if you break it now
it's cursed that's true no one knows
my alien ghost here we go
so hello guys damn i don't understand an
indonesian language dude no
listening
i hear guys a lot so i heard guys a lot
hello guys
by the way that's the gift that youtube
gave the world is everyone opens their
videos and says hey guys
even if they have one view it's like
what's up guys we all see
it it's crashed through the awning
it's like one of those things where like
you know a person flies through a wall
in a cartoon it's like a shape of a
person
that was the exact shape of it yeah
luckily
it didn't hit his actual home
oh i thought it was destroyed his home
and then like
no it was just like a kitchen no it just
it was just this
it would be so cool though if like a
meteor comes down
destroys the [ __ ] out of his house he's
like no and then like he
finds the meteor and they're like guess
what though you get a better house
and he's like oh thank god so imagine if
like a boring meteor came through
they're like this one's a relatively new
one it's worth nothing
and then you look at your insurance like
this insurance doesn't cover meteors
why do i buy this insurance this is made
out of nickel which is very common sorry
[ __ ] off oh that sucks
yeah so his name is joshua and he's 33
years old he's a coffin maker oh
wow he was yes he was because now
he is two million dollars richard now
he's retired
now he's just rich he's retired now look
at that that kid smile he's like my
daddy got a big ranch yeah it's pretty
interesting
and so they said that they found other
meteorites like within the radius of his
home
oh wow oh like a bunch of them came out
around that time
yeah okay yeah i hope it collects all of
them yeah cells all of them
yeah they're saying that they found
another one discovered discovered nearby
uh fewer than five miles do they think
it was like one big one
that broke apart yeah that's what
they're saying they're saying that they
think it was just one that like
scattered we're supposed to have one
that comes and crashes down but i'm
hoping that it'll break apart and we can
just get rich off of it
that'll be a nice treat you know it's
kind of like a bunch of humans win
meteors and then they like can sell it
instead of like
it just goes into our atmosphere and
kills us all elon will stop it
you think so you believe in him all
right bruce willis ben affleck
they're going to blow it up outside i
hope they got to find drillers
astronauts can't do it because they
don't know how to drill that's right
i lived a pretty good life though but i
wouldn't want to die for a meteor
i don't know if the meteor was coming
down right now and you had no choice
would you be like i'm ready to die i'd
be like yeah
i had a pretty sick ass life bro what a
joke you already answered for me that i
have no choice no no but then but then
would you feel that feeling of like but
i
didn't [ __ ] do everything and [ __ ]
yeah
i don't want to have kids what if they
give you a time limit they said it's
going to be here in an
hour you better start [ __ ] your last
hour oh what would i do it happened
right now oh my god
i wouldn't make it home in time no all
the traffic because everyone else is
watching too
so we're gonna hang out with everybody
here one hour two what would he all do
together
right now i think the first thing bart
is going to do is get you hard and touch
your dick
he wants to feel what it's like get hard
in the state of panic that you know
you're about to think i need to satisfy
the science feeling
this hat hasn't been fulfilled for for
bart's
dying wish for my friends i think if i
had an hour
i would and depending on where geo is
and taika is i would try to go
i'm gonna google first the part the
nearest parking garage
that is the deepest into the ground and
look for solutions
yeah and see uh which one is like a 10
foot before
below 10 story below ground parking
garage a parking garage because you know
there's like a [ __ ] ton of tunnels just
underneath us but i don't know how to
get to them i know google that
you are a man of solutions
the meteor is going to [ __ ] us all up
like there's not going to be anything
alive
it's going to break earth art like it's
going to break it apart all right like
the earth like cracks in half or
something yeah oh [ __ ] i'd be like
nelson
shots all black shots too then [ __ ]
yeah
i think that yeah before you fall asleep
on the shots you
like you get to enjoy at least before
you fall asleep yeah yeah
then maybe i'll find a diving board and
try to time myself
diving into the meter as it hits
your two options are either i'm gonna
try to survive this or i'm gonna dive
into the meat even faster yeah
man i would spend all my time just [ __ ]
rules i'm driving on
grass and everything i could possibly
drive i'm taking bart's car
if you're staying here oh no yeah i'm
taking you drop him off at the diving
board and then keep going yeah yeah
and then just [ __ ] hauling ass to get
home and i just want to be with casey
and isaac and hugging and just be like
i'll put a rope on the on the truck that
you're driving and then i'll have my
skateboard
so i could enjoy life while i'm dying oh
[ __ ]
he dies within five minutes and turns
out the scientists are like uh the meter
is going to miss us
oh joe's dead already and bart's on a
diving board
[Laughter]
yeah is there like another option where
we can like all the homies that have
guns
we go and just start shooting you know
we would
you don't want to come back down and
then kill everyone
that's the best thing about i feel like
all humans
what we'll do is we'll get all the
a-bombs and everything that we got
to shoot at the meteor yeah but then
what if it's like made out of some
different material we don't even know
and then it ends up like bouncing back
bulletproof meteor and it just shoots us
back
can we die yeah damn there's no yeah
there's no way to deal with it dude it's
crazy i would not make it home that's
sad
because there's no way in traffic i
wouldn't make it home if i knew i had
now mickey would just hop on the other
car because you guys have two cars
and everyone's going to try to do the
same thing that's what i'm saying [ __ ]
rules just [ __ ] drive over buildings
i don't have a car that can drive over
buildings i know yeah
how hard do you think it's gonna is it
gonna hit earth so hard it smashes all
the water off of it
like how hard is this going i just
picture like slapping it
into the [ __ ] second moon
oh yeah it's gonna make us we land on
the moon
in an hour we gotta get to the spaceship
fly to the moon
no i'm saying from the impact of the
smack breaks our piece flies off like
wow guys this is pretty cool
what if the meteor hits the earth
destroys the [ __ ] out of it and then the
whole solar system
and then it create it just start the big
bang starts all over again oh yeah
from a meteor huh isn't that how it
started no
not from a meteor but then it just
destroys the earth but the
destruction of that [ __ ] breaks it
apart
and it comes back and it [ __ ] goes it
creates a black hole
and then it's like okay another earth
that's how the moon was created
yeah you know what i learned from the
videos that taika watches
so this just blew my mind because my
understanding of the solar system
is the sun's here right and the earth is
going around the sun
right did you know that the sun itself
is also rotating so it's actually like
this
so it's actually the entire solar system
is not just spinning around itself it's
the whole thing
everything's kind of moving that's why
they say we're hurtling through the
cosmos yeah i'm like i didn't [ __ ]
know that [ __ ]
because i always thought the sun was in
the galaxy is going yeah i mean same
thing with
the earth and the moon the moon isn't
really going around the earth it's like
a pivotal moment in the middle yeah
where they kind of rotate around that's
why in a way
our galaxy is almost like a spaceship
traveling through the universe
yeah and i saw that i'm like wow and
then tycho looked at me like yep
there's nothing that's still no nothing
literally nothing not everybody is a
fidgety [ __ ]
that means it's it's like [ __ ] it it
might it must be
destined if we're [ __ ] quadruple
spinning
and this one thing that's coming in a
straight line hits us it's like [ __ ] it
just accept it then
exactly no fight dude fight yeah that's
fine [ __ ] let's find a parking garage
and figure it out
i like it
[Music]
you